Right before you took the chief
executive role, you spent some time
as a driver. Can you tell us a
little bit about what that
experience was like?
The best thing about driving for
Lyft was that I got to meet great
riders. You know, my third
couple that I drove had just
come out of a restaurant when I
picked them up. This was their first
restaurant meal since Covid in San
Francisco. They had been very
cautious and they went to a
restaurant called Earnest.
It had been open for maybe six
months. I had never heard of it.
A week later, my wife and I went
there.
And were there any sort of things
you noticed when you were a driver
that might result in sort of changes
to either product or process?
Oh a ton.
I mean, again, from a riders
perspective, look, our launch today
around travel, it's like, let's
figure out a way to make things
really easy for for riders because
that's what they want. And then
drivers really want and enjoy
the control they have over their own
lives, right?
They can drive when they want.
They don't have to ask someone for
permission. And so we're really
going to focus on some of those
basics to make sure that, you know,
we want people Lyft loyal.
We want people to say, "I've got
both apps, but I should have taken a
Lyft."
And you've worked with some very
influential people in tech.
I mean, Bill Gates and Jeff Bezos.
Is there any piece of advice that
either of them have given you that
you still hold on to now that you're
CEO of Lyft?
Yeah. I mean, I'll focus on Jeff
Bezos. He really set focus on the
customer. So, for example, what we
launched today is, you know, your
plane wheels touch down.
The flight attendant says you can
turn your phone on and
all you have to do is open the Lyft
app. Answer one question:
Do you have baggage or not?
And then hit go and then we take
care of the rest so that by the time
you're at the curb, the car has
already arrived.
And just think about that for a
second. Think of the stress that you
have as soon as your plane is there.
Is my baggage here or not?
How am I going to get to the hotel?
What's going to happen next?
You can outsource a lot of that
stress to us.
That's what we want to do.
And that really is Jeff Bezos.
You know, sort of I'm just copying
his strategy. It Work pretty well
for Amazon, and I think it can work
pretty well for Lyft and our
customers.